don't bring anyone love into this hey
don't try actually met Brendan I was at
a fight he doesn't even know this but
probably but I met him at a fight and I
cheered against him that's good so I was
going to these fights because I was I
was I was touring with Joe with Rogen's
tickets yeah but I was I was opening for
him yeah and I think it was in Vancouver
maybe Oh I found Arlovski no I think I
thought you fought matryona Doug I'll
bet you're on yes yes yes so drunk but I
don't know what's wrong okay I don't
know any I didn't I didn't know anybody
in the u.s. you know I mean like I know
some of the big names but yeah I mean
I'm you know I like football stuff so
I'm sitting there and and Cowan shows up
and he's like my boys fighting in this I
was like who's your boy and so we're
like it's like the weigh-ins you know
and I can he's like he's coming up it's
coming up and then he goes and he's
telling me about like this is what this
guy does this was this guy he goes yeah
my boys fighting this guy they used to
play college football so there I go you
know I'm like a big I go where whoo
where he goes up he says metrion I go
Mitrione I go pretty late ball he goes I
thought you said LSU so I go LSU I go
ask my dog I'm like go Tigers do so so
then at the winds I go yo man like Ellis
who's gonna fuck you out and then at the
fights man it was made I was sitting
next to Cowen you would have thought it
was Cowan's seven-year-old son I mean he
was like nervous as shit he was so
nervous and like like trying to get your
attention like every fucking I was like
and I kept being like you boys make it
fuck dude he was like he wasn't listen
to anything I was saying he was so and
you won that fight yeah man when you won
the fight he fucking lost his mind
yeah dude he was he was like it was like
a father and son what's in which he
could be since he's that much older than
you hunter presenting yeah my dad yeah
[Music]